hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today i present
to you a rather late review of chapter
147 of jujutsu kaisen then again there's
no new chapter this week so
you have nothing better to do than to
watch this video anyway
so fun fact i'm actually writing this
review after having completed the blind
review series which is a bit
awkward due to the timing of editing and
such but for my overall sense of
completion
i need to cover this because as a person
who has been 100
on team panda from the very moment he
was introduced this was heartbreaking
heartbreaking but also
sickeningly funny because in my review
of the current arc i said something
along the lines of hoping that principal
janka gets expanded upon because we
really know nothing about him and
well i suppose this is a case of uh be
careful what you wish for
and while we're here you should wish for
more jujutsukaisen content then kindly
form a binding vowel by hitting the
subscribe button for the new world
review doing so will practically force
me to produce more videos covering this
wonderful series for your consumpting
pleasure but getting into it chapter 147
is all about masamichiaga a character
that to me has always been rather
unfortunately on the sidelines despite
his position of prominence in the series
and i have to say i got a sinking
feeling about this chapter the moment i
saw the cover page it's very simple it's
panda holding what i assumed was yaga's
hand and just
ah and very wary as such sweet imagery
injured skysim because it's generally
used as an appetizer for tragedy
something to make sure you really get
hit in the gut by what's about to happen
a more extreme example of this would be
the whole
jinpei mother situation she was a
character designed to be as lackable as
possible in order to have the pain of
her death hit that much harder that's
how i see this cover page a very likable
cute and sweet image designed to
completely and utterly destroy us from
the inside and that's what it did
but before we get into that this chapter
was really great in terms of expanding
the field of cursed corpses like we've
had this discussion before when mcmurra
fought against panda but there is indeed
something very special about mr pander
as well as the rest of janka's creations
there's a pretty in-depth explanation
around the end of the chapter stating
that creating an independent corpse
involves replicating soul information
and needing to house three of these soul
drives in one vessel which eventually
evolves into a self-sustaining cursed
energy machine and this immediately
contributes a ton to a conversation that
jujutsu kaisen has been having since
i think the dawn of the series which is
what is a soul how do we quantify
it and how is it tied to the body is it
tied to the body mahito's answer is that
the soul was paramount and controls the
shape of the body meanwhile the
phenomena of toji went on to suggest
that the body and soul can't really be
separate and even the suggestion of a
body could go on to generate
its own soul and now here we are with
yaga who claims to be able to replicate
soul-based entities on purely physical
information without
impacting the shape of the new body
every time soul information is brought
up we get a very simple explanation
attached to it however each one of these
explanations of what souls are and how
to manipulate them tend to contradict
the previous idea which is great because
it is a complicated issue and in the end
who even knows if a soul
even exists i don't you don't unless you
do
if you do let me know in the comments
i'm very curious but i tell you what
this whole chapter gives new meaning to
the term
cursed corpse i've always been intrigued
by that title because i don't think
we've ever seen an actual corpse used
for this technique however in yaga's
case specifically the corpse does not
refer to the remnants of the body but
rather the remnants of the soul which
was gathered from the body and just
yeah i find it really interesting
especially when you think about the
example that was given in chapter 147
takuru the cute cartoony
corpse with a tie firstly there's an
interesting question of how
ethical it is to seemingly quite
literally create a copy of someone
else's soul and that's a question we're
sort of beginning to tackle in the real
world right now with celebrity deep
fakes and using the likeness of dead
people to perform in films and
advertising it's a really weird
and uncomfortable question but here it's
taken to a whole new level because as
heartwarming as this
sort of is part of me does feel really
uncomfortable with copying the soul of
that woman's dead son like in theory
there is no harm in it for this
particular situation
because it was used to give the woman a
reason to live there's just something
that
ah doesn't feel quite right which is
pretty perfectly jujutsu
i don't think it's supposed to feel
right because even our good guys in this
series are ultimately
dealing with very morally questionable
powers across the board and this is just
the latest iteration it's bigger than
that though because this also speaks to
literally being able to create life
because this isn't takaru it's like an
amalgamation of three people housed
within a single vessel so in effect this
becomes an entirely new existence
just molded from the characteristics of
the other three but i think the true
tragedy really sets in when you realize
that panda or at least part of panda was
in fact yanka's son it's not explicitly
stated but the implication i get is that
just like this woman
yaga's son died under tragic
circumstances so his soul was replicated
and is now contributing to the existence
that is the glorious pandar so that's
quite tragically touching here because
obviously yaga could heavily identify
with the woman's situation and even
though he technically understands the
existence of both panda and takaru he
still cannot help but see
panda as his son that took a while to
really sink in with me but i think about
that panel now where yoga claims that
he's going to see his son
and it's tough to read just like a lot
of this chapter
especially in retrospect and you know
i'm very much not
looking forward to seeing this animated
however many years that may take from
now because with voice acting and music
this could be a properly tear-generating
and soul-destroying moment rather
ironically and definitely the ending
with panda as well this stupid panel
ah even pandas cry i hate this panel
because it does exactly what i said by
punching you in the gut after setting up
this really sweet bond and i want to
emphasize for the people who
take things very literally i don't
actually hate this panel it's very
beautiful
and emotional but i hate looking at it
because it generates
many many feels while run panda we had a
very intriguing exchange with
gaku ganji someone who i now despise
with all of my being
despite how damn cool he looks with that
guitar but panda really laid some
foundations here with the whole human
behavior's don't bind panda speech and
his ability to look past
reactionary human inclinations in a
weird way panda represents
a level of evolution the sort of stuff
that jogo was spouting about an entirely
new breed of true humans panda is human
at his core
or cause plural but he exists on an
entirely different plane of concerns and
what can i say panda is the best of us
and good on akutami for taking the super
weird concept of a panda sorcerer and
turning it into a deeply emotional
journey it also screw akutami for doing
that having brought up
old mate gakuganji earlier something
else not to be understated in this
chapter
yaga's last words all he had to do in
order to live was reveal the formula for
crafting these insane thai wielding
existences and in the end he did the
exact opposite by revealing it only when
death was certain
claiming that this was a curse imparted
onto gakuganji and i guess that's a
curse of knowledge rather than anything
to do with energy or technique so
gakuganji is now the sole individual who
understands this process
and he is left with quite a burden of
whether or not to share this information
with the higher ups thus potentially
leading to creating an
army of soul-based corpses which sounds
horrifying because at that point we are
well beyond the ethical line of copying
souls and more into the arena of
enslaving copied souls and it's now very
much the responsibility of our other
principle to decide what
to do with that also just a note nice
touch that it ultimately came down to a
showdown between the principals kyoto
and tokyo
sad that kyoto prevailed but what can
you do and you know what all of a sudden
jutsu high is a pretty rubbish place to
be there's no gojo
no yaga just evil old administrators
sitting behind
what what even are they sitting behind
just like these panels
i think but come to think of it they've
really sort of succeeded haven't they
they think yuji is dead due to the
binding of alfremuta yaga is now
actually dead and gojo remains sealed in
the prison realm from their perspective
everything is going ridiculously well
like i've said before shibuya was an
absolute gift to them and that's
important because before now i don't
think we've been given
too strong a reason to dislike these
mysterious administrators since the
beginning gojo has expressed his own
hatred of the system but we are only
really just now getting to see the
system in action and it's pretty
horrific you can definitely see how all
of these curses have manifested in the
world because there are people out there
who are indistinguishable from you know
being a curse
they are a curse on humanity not
literally but
sort of but forever making things far
worse for their own desires and in the
end actual weird-looking scary curses
are just symptoms of this problem we are
going to need to tackle the actual
problem sooner or later because it's
always better to cure
disease rather than to constantly be in
a state of attempting to treat it what i
will say is that it does give our
protagonists this wonderful rogue
feeling now because they really have no
allies
on one side they are faced with a legion
of curses striving to kill them and on
the other we have a system of humans who
are also
gunning for most of them so we really
are in the lowest moment of the story so
far for our main characters
yuji in particular but also not to be
ignored kusukabe was featured in this
chapter and in fact it was his sister
who was the woman who could not live
without her corpse son
i always like learning more about kusaka
though and even though he's very
pro-ug execution he is a pretty cool guy
although to be honest
sometimes it's also quite easy to see
how one can be in favor of killing yuji
like yes it's a very tough decision but
the risk of sukuna is a threat to all
humanity so this whole yuji thing is a
gigantic gamble which because it's
shonen is probably going to pay off but
some people just
aren't inclined to risk as much as say
gojo and fushiguru now in terms of art
there's a couple of highlights during
this chapter
firstly i love how all of yaga's cursed
corpses are drawn they're very sketchy
and
kind of quite bland i mean bland is
probably the wrong word but all the
words i can think of sound
kind of negative at first like instead
of bland you could also call them flat
unrefined
simplistic but that's exactly their
charm like this takaru
thing doesn't look like he belongs in
jiu-jitsu kaisen and neither do any of
the other corpses they're all these
beautifully simplistic childlike figures
ripped straight out of a cartoon
and by the way f this panel the one
where they're all saying
we'll miss you because in retrospect
this is this is probably even a bigger
gut punch than the pandas crying thing
reading this
knowing that this is the last time
they'll ever see him is like saying
goodbye to a pet or a loved one and i
hate it stop toying with my emotions
like this akutami have you not done
enough already have you not are you not
entertained by my pain but the point was
which i started to make is that i like
their deliberate simplicity it
emphasizes their innocence and purity
and all of that and the other noteworthy
point of art was our final panel where
akutami elected to depict panda
wailing with this image of moth
surrounding a street lamp and then
having a close-up of assumedly one dead
moth was our final panel so as much as i
love light being depicted in manga i
didn't get this at first but having
looked into it the symbolism is very
clear in japanese because yaga can
apparently be translated as
moth so during this chapter we see
masumi chiyaga get killed and then to
really hammer that idea home we see a
creature of his namesake
also dead yes it's just a really
depressing visual metaphor and in fact
this chapter was
was really depressing in general wasn't
it i came into it being all excited
to learn more about the culling game
maybe meet another new contestant and
instead i am hit over the head with pain
and emotion
and then another round of pain pain
which only becomes worse when you read
the chapter for a second time oh it is
so much worse
but look while it was a very sudden end
to mr yaga a character that i really
wanted to expand on a lot more it did
work
undeniably well it's not because of yaga
himself though i maintained that he was
still quite underutilized and
underexplored but what's important here
are his cursed corpses
those are the feelings that we empathize
with from the simple notion of takaru
and the rest
missing yaga to the extreme of panda
tears
i feel bad for the cursed corpses more
so than i do for yaga but it doesn't
really matter so long as the tragedy
does its job
and it does just that good job akitami
you've ruined me
once again and that pretty much does it
for chapter 147 of jujutsu kaisen and
screw this chapter but what do you guys
think please leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
jujutsu sorcery then please do check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular jujutsu kaiser morbidity
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time